your questions now and uh so many on the
issue of those atrocities and uh we'll
start
with d in a moment just let you know uh
professor michael clark's going to be
our security and defense analyst is
going to be uh answering those as many
of them as we can for you but dee uh
asking about these
alleged atrocities um asking what so so
many people are thinking michael though
what can the west do to halt the killing
of innocent civilians well i mean that
takes in what we've talked about before
about um intervention no fly zones what
what can be done directly nothing
but indirectly actually more than people
think
because this is the first war the first
which in which war crimes issues have
arisen from the very beginning
it's so it's a world in which we're
living now in which open source
intelligence is freely available you
know there are a world of people out
there who are digging through images who
know quite a lot who can do forensics
the satellite imagery
any intelligence chief will tell you any
british intelligence chief will tell you
quite openly that more than 90
in some cases 95
of everything they deal with is open
source intelligence the five percent
that's really secret is gold dust and
that's the five percent but the vast
majority is open source and what we've
got here i mean as you know the report
was we've been we've been looking at
what happened on la banza uh yablonska
street in butcher those are the with
those are the bodies in in
uh in that street and the russians
insisted that those bodies were put
there after they left on the 30th to the
31st of march but now maxar have
produced an image which shows what
appear to be exactly the same bodies in
exactly the same place exactly
referenced by the things next to them
and the shadows
that they create and the maxar image is
the 19th of march so it's pretty
conclusive that those bodies have been
lying there since at least the 19th of
march and then the ukrainians did
something very interesting yesterday
they issued a list which they said they
had captured
of the 64th motor rifle brigade who were
the last unit to leave butcher and they
and that list was names ranks and
passport numbers of a great many of
those troops and so they were saying
look if this constitute war crimes then
there are people in this brigade this
motor rifle brigade who can be
pinpointed and so we can do more than
you think because of open source
intelligence to make it clear to russian
soldiers that the nuremberg tradition
applies that is to say i was only
obeying orders is no defense and it's
part of the russian tactics though to
continue to deny this reality you know
we've heard it we've heard it there they
have the united nations we heard it from
sergey lavrov the foreign minister
yesterday we've heard it in syria we've
heard it it's salisbury yeah it's a
tactic isn't it they do they always go
through three stages first of all they
deny it outright just ridiculous don't
be foolish then they start to obfuscate
so they create lots of complications oh
they might even nurse and it might have
been that and look at what else was
happening at the time and they create
new stuff that seems to make it very
complicated so no simple picture could
really emerge and then a couple of years
later they admitted in the face of all
the others said yes we did we did do it
but you do it as well and they try to
create moral equivalence to say look
this is the world this is cynicism this
is the world we live in and so it goes
through denial obfuscation and then
moral equivalence it's a standard tactic
and to do it every time okay let's get
another question on the same subjects
tom asked this what's the possibility of
russian forces being tried for war
crimes and how hard would it be to bring
vladimir putin to justice well you kind
of addressed the first part of that
question all already michael there have
been some of the forces
personally identified who were in the
region and certainly would face
questions but what about tracing it all
the way the chain of command all the way
to the top
quite difficult of course um but the the
indictment as a war criminal is
something that hangs on leaders and in
vladimir putin's case this is a real big
one because previous leaders who've been
indicted have been from fairly small
countries with who've committed
atrocities in africa mainly and in
former yugoslavia this is of course the
biggest case ever and if putin in in a
sense is indicted then that will send a
message to a lot of other dictators
around the globe will he ever appear in
front of a war crimes tribe you know
only if he falls
and is handed over by some sort of
future government of russia that's quite
hard to imagine but living under the
shadow of a war crimes indictment would
would mean that in theory if he traveled
to any of the countries that are
signatories to the international
criminal court he could be arrested
which is actually quite an interesting
pressure
but does in the in the reality of the
situation does it make a peace deal more
difficult in that if you're saying right
we're going to arrest you if you so much
as put a foot outside russian territory
it might that's what we used to say
about saddam hussein that the more we
demonize him the harder it will be for
him to back down the argument against
that is that putin has already crossed
his rubicon you know he's burned so many
bridges behind him he's only got he can
only go forward and he will continue to
do that and that trying to negotiate
with this man is the argument is now too
difficult and we've got to actually
stand up for what is basically right and
decent and civilized that's the counter
argument although there are there are
downsides to going through this process
of legalizing everything the upside is
just too big and we've got to grasp the
upside because this is a this is the the
struggle of our era this is the this is
the struggle that will define us for the
next 50 years in europe okay well let's
stay with that issue uh this from will
is it a deliberate act of russian
military policy to intimidate civilians
or evidence of a breakdown in military
discipline and morale well we mentioned
their previous instance of it i mean
do you tend towards the the former
it's probably both i mean there are
deliberate acts of military policy we
know that the russvardia who are the
internal troops who are there they're
the enforcement troops the police um
who've been brought in on the back of
the uh the military force themselves
they don't fight but they work through
the civilians they actually keep order
and we know that the
um have lists of people that they
intended to pick up and we also know
that where there has been some passive
resistance that the russians have
responded and they've retaliated so a
certain amount of this
intimidation and abuse is probably
deliberately retaliatory
quite a lot of what we're seeing i'm
sure is in discipline because the
russian forces have very weak
non-commissioned officers they they're
nco cadre the sergeants the corporals
who are there to actually keep order
among the troops to make the troops
behave properly and professionally to
drive them forward to help them to act
as their mothers you know the their nco
card is very poor always was in the red
army it is in this army but we know they
had lists lists of of people that when
they take areas they were going to round
up that's right lists of people who were
political activists um ngo people
politicians journalists i mean british
and american intelligence said that they
know they have these lists and when we
looked at what happened in um cursion
which they which they did occupy um we
saw those lists being carried through we
saw you know we saw mayors of places
being carted away um and replaced with
puppet mayors who were all uh ready to
go and some of that's been reversed now
but it's undoubtedly the rosvaria came
in in order to sort of stalinize the
areas that the russians took over and in
terms of that ill discipline we've also
seen images
from belarus where russian forces so
many of them have withdrawn two of them
in courier companies dispatching some of
their looted goods
back home and you know what that tells
us that there is organized criminality
right down to the lowest levels because
the ukrainians have discovered when
they've captured tanks sometimes they
found fridges inside looted fridges
looted microwaves and they filled their
tanks and their vehicles with all these
household goods that they've looted now
they're not going to carry them all the
way back to russia in their tanks so
what are they doing they're swapping
that for cash quite close to where they
looted it and somebody else is then
taking it to distribution centers taking
it into belarus into russia to sell it
on the black market what that tells us
is that there is organized criminality
right right down to the unit level of
these forces that have gone into ukraine
it couldn't operate otherwise very
organized process which again tells us
about the lack of discipline
at the lower levels of the units indeed
okay uh this from thomas um the united
states has called for russia to be
kicked out of the u.n human rights
council let's be clear human rights
council can they be kicked out of the
u.n security council this was something
mark stone was just addressing well the
u.n security council not as such because
they've got veto on the council not a
chance what about the u.n human rights
council uh that's possible and that
would be entirely symbolic you know
there are certain things the un does
well and certainly it doesn't do very
well and the human rights council is one
of those things it really doesn't do
very well at all um everyone is a member
of the council and they have 47 members
who rotate every three years
as an executive the present executive is
led by an argentinian and they're there
for the
2022 to 24 period
and sometimes the human rights council
comes up with the most egregious
foolishness i mean the chinese block any
discussion of xinjiang and the uyghurs
the human rights council regularly goes
after israel on palestinian issues but
won't talk about other things
um the united states tries to try to
protect israel on the human rights
council it is a bun fight and to be
honest it doesn't have a whole lot to do
with human rights it's one of those
areas of the un machinery which is
probably the most hypocritical
but
uh to to throw russia out symbolically
it won't make any difference except that
it increases that sense of isolation
that russia under putin does not belong
in the civilized family of nations
that's the message but the door has to
be kept open then you say it's a symbol
under putin yeah but do we have to say
to russia look well you know if this
changes you can oh for sure i mean the
western allies are very keen to say look
we don't have a quarrel with the russian
people the russian people are it's a
great civilization it's part of europe
and asia our issue is with this man who
has adopted the stalinist mantle and
whilst putin is in charge we we find we
can't deal with you once he is not in
charge in whatever way in which he he
gives up power we will be delighted to
deal with russia as we think it should
be dealt with let's get another question
you know what more
can be done to protect people and andy
asked this is there any way united
nations peacekeepers could move into
ukraine to assist at least with
humanitarian aid and you and
peacekeepers are drawn from forces
around the world yeah they are um
by and large they say well you can't
have um peacekeepers until there's a
piece to keep but if there were
ceasefires then it's plausible wouldn't
be easy but it's plausible that u.n
forces could actually try to they can't
keep the ceasefire but they could
actually operate humanitarian corridors
they could help deliver humanitarian aid
that's exactly what the british were
doing um through the u.n in yugoslavia
in 1992
it was a you and you the on preferred
operation but very quickly of course
they found they were fighting they were
there just to deliver deliver food and
you know talk to bob stewart now who's
colonel bob stewart who's an mp
conservative mp i mean he led the um it
was a cheshire regiment i think it was
um uh into uh uh into you former
yugoslavia and within a couple of months
they were fighting because
you can't deliver humanitarian aid in a
in a volatile situation without having
somehow to to take sides in order to do
your job so it's not out of the question
but we'd have to be somewhere else in
this war for it to become feasible i
would say okay michael we're going to
pause it there and then get to plenty
more questions just to let you know
you're watching a special question and
answer program on the war in ukraine
next we're asking about the weather yes
it's very significant is russia about to
face what it has been avoiding all along
[Music]
[Music]
the world seems to be becoming more and
more divided issues around politics
culture the pandemic are resulting in
vastly opposing viewpoints causing real
risks between us
i want to get in the middle of those
debates i want to better understand
where each stance comes from and whether
there's room for compromise join me
trevor phillips as we look to find
common ground on sky news
yeah i tried to do this basic i couldn't
work for the basic people e5 on the late
shift papa knows i can't afford to waste
gifts not to justify the waiting
reinvent yourself amazing you don't have
to decide to make all in your mind is
undiscovered greatness
sometimes at times hesitate to get
involved we actually started this
company to champion black stories and
black talent but also just tell diverse
stories so we're very very happy that
these films are showing this week
i grew up in an environment that i feel
like had certain expectations of black
ways the way that you have to carry
yourself the way that you had to
communicate the way that you had to
dress and i think a lot of it was
survival mechanisms that lent into toxic
masculinity however when i left this
area and i went to university and i
started working in the arts i felt that
i had to do the opposite i almost had to
code switch to make people that i was
around feel comfortable and almost
dispel the stereotype of black boys and
black men that was in media and so like
after that i almost felt like i didn't
fit into either of these worlds and none
of them were a true representation of
who i was and so i wanted to make a film
about that impulse of wearing you need
to that impulsive space where you need
to decide who you want to be as a man
and so that's essentially what butterfly
effect is about
yeah i mean music videos
were and have been an amazing i guess
stomping ground to be able to cut my
teeth in terms of direction and working
with talent and it's been amazing i
think like we've been able to create
like a few moments that have lived on in
the in the world of music videos and
hopefully they'll
be joined by some narrative work i'm
going to do going forward as well
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back you're watching sky news
tonight and i'm with professor michael
clark and your questions about the war
in ukraine let's get our next one this
is uh from robin he's asking about the
potential for us to look beyond
ukraine's borders and ask this should we
help fortify odessa to stop russia
taking the strategic port city and
gaining a land corridor in the south to
moldova well michael first of all just
you have to inform us about the
geography that if that was the ambition
that would also cut ukraine off from the
sea correct yeah i mean odessa is the
main porter onto the black sea now that
the ukrainians lost sevastopol of course
when they lost the crimea in 2014 so
odessa's the main port um and uh the
russians looked as if they certainly
wanted to take odetta in the early stage
of the war we thought they would they
got held up at mikalayev which is about
18 miles away 80 miles to the east
they've been pushed back even from
nicolette so they're now further away
from odessa than they were before and it
looked as if they had an amphibious
landing capability as well and
what we thought was that they would move
in on odessa from the landward side once
they'd taken uh mikalayev and then
their amphibious group would then go in
with the land forces to support them
just didn't happen um and you know
should we help fortify odessa says robin
absolutely it's a good idea because
quite a lot of what we could give to the
ukrainians would make a difference in
odessa
because odessa is quite a tough nut as a
city to take and it's a it's a very
tough nut of a city to assault from the
sea
and so the the ukrainians have got their
own neptune uh anti-ship missiles and
they've been quite successful with at
least one of their neptunes recently we
might give them our harpoon weapons we
have an anti-ship missile called harpoon
which is pretty good we've also got a
thing called sea venom which is launched
from a wildcat helicopter
and they're more agile because you can
send them in a helicopter somewhere else
before they before they launch so there
are things that we could do and i know
that number 10 is very interested
in seeing what might make a difference
but yes i mean robin is is absolutely
right odessa is a big strategic issue if
the russians can't take it that
represents quite a big failure in what
they can achieve in ukraine and it's
probably worth the ukrainians putting a
lot of effort in and also putting a lot
of effort into helping them maintain it
michael i've just got a quick question
then if that is to happen about lines of
supply if the fighting moves away from
the north moves away from kiev getting
that weaponry to the ukrainian forces is
a far far greater distance does that
make them more vulnerable to attack well
it might be easier if the lines of
supply could go through romania or even
moldova which are right next door i mean
moldova is only 30 miles away the
moldovan board is only 30 miles away
from odessa so if we could use those
routes if those countries would let us
then supply would be easier i was
actually talking to an mod official um
about a week ago and we asked about the
lines of supply and he was actually
surprisingly relaxed about it he was
saying no as long as these cities are
open like kharkiv and sumi which they
now are he said we can get stuff in and
i was really quite surprised because i
thought well
some pretty big distances there and i
didn't i didn't press it i don't want to
know um well i do want to know but but i
shouldn't know so i i didn't press him
but he said no no we can we can get
stuff in we you know there are different
ways of doing it and we can keep the
ukrainians supplied um as long as we
agree to do it and we do it with our
allies that's very good to hear now i'm
a question uh from mervin and uh it's
well it's about conflict with russia and
the weather how often does that pop up
uh marin says sir why have russia
invaded when the spring thor brings mud
that makes movement of mechanized armies
very difficult to like those tanks good
question though very good question i
mean that was why we all said when we
were thinking about this possibility
back before the 24th of february we said
and i said a few times on various
programs the window of opportunity for
the russians will go from about early
february to about mid to late march
because then the ground will get soft
and armored vehicles will find it much
more difficult to move over soft ground
and the weather forecast i checked on
the weather this this week in ukraine
and monday was a pretty cold day so it's
still only eight or nine degrees both in
kiev and in miklev in the south a bit
warmer in odessa but this week here we
are on what tuesday and by the end of
this week it'll be 18 or 19 degrees
throughout ukraine with rain
and so the weather is warming up the
spring rains are coming the ground is
softening and the russians of course
expected to have all this over by the
8th of march their original plan was
three days to take kiev and then mopping
up operations in other cities which
would be really glad to see them by the
8th of march so here they are today is
day 40 of the war the 40th day of the
war and the weather as it improves will
turn against what they are trying to do
which is use heavy armor in rapid
movements trying to envelop the
ukrainian army and so on ukrainians will
have the easier job because they dug in
and if they can hold their current
positions they don't have to fight a war
of maneuver to quite the same extent in
the southeast but if the russians are to
succeed they've got to maneuver an awful
lot better than they have so far
and the weather is against them mervin's
absolutely right yeah well i mentioned
uh the weather and conflicts with russia
i mean could it could in a way i mean
it's it's a long way off and in very
different weather conditions you know
we've all read about what happened to
napoleon's armies in the winter and
hitler yeah
and the winter
this this is the spring the weather
doing to the russians what previously
it's done to their enemies
you know i mean
battles and warfare is so much about the
conditions so much about the conditions
and you know at c they always say that
that the issue of sea power is about
coping with the seed the enemy are just
another damn nuisance you know the issue
is coping with the sea and so much of
military success is dealing with the
conditions
and the conditions changing there and
thank you very much for casting your
your eye over the ukrainian weather
forecast as we would expect michael of
course we're taking another break you're
watching a special question and answer
program on the war in ukraine next we're
asking how long can the russians last in
ukraine and could ukrainians start
striking back into russia itself stay
with us
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
welcome back i'm with professor michael
clark and your questions on the war in
ukraine now let's get one from alan now
about armor we were just before the
break discussing tanks and their
maneuverability in the weather
conditions uh alan asks how much more
ammunition and firepower has russia got
left to continue its invasion well we've
been seeing long lists of what the
ukrainians have destroyed what have they
got left
yes i mean the russians have lost uh at
least 2
100 pieces of significant equipment and
the ukrainians have lost about 600
650. so the russians have lost three or
four times what ukrainians have lost but
the russians have huge stocks of course
and there are all sorts of stories about
the the getting some of the older tanks
out of the stock and so on what's
interesting i think about allen's
question is that the russians have got
any amount of old cold war stuff so
they've got their howitzers that their
self-propelled howitzers their towed um
artillery and they've got any number of
shells uh 20 20 years 30 years old to
fire on them what they look to be short
of is modern missiles and they've fired
well over a thousand missiles and it
looks as if they are running short of
them because they haven't fired as many
recently and we think that that's one of
the things that they asked the chinese
for when they went to the chinese and
said we need more ammunition there's
another
there's another element here which is
that that because they expected to take
over ukraine quickly they thought that
they would take over kharkiv and israel
really quickly now they haven't got
either of those cities and israel is
where the ukrainians are fighting really
hard where's his is in the donbass
region it was it's the ukrainian
headquarters really in the donbass and
kharkiv and isiam is the place where
they make all the motors the engines for
russian missiles russian tanks russian
ships so that their engine factories are
in ukraine most of them and so the
russians had to have to conquer those
cities in order to get hold of the
engines that they need for their new uh
production of missiles and so one of the
things that's that's problematical for
them is that they they can't ramp up
quickly enough to produce the stuff that
they need in the high-tech area so yeah
they've got any amount of old-fashioned
stuff they can pound cities to rubble
with cold war artillery but if you're
talking about modern missiles they're
stuck
astonishing about isiam i did not know
that michael thank you um well this is
about the ukrainian side of the equation
then why isn't ukraine bombing or
targeting missile strikes on parts of
russia as both countries are at war with
each other that's from sarah well it
goes without saying a massive country um
but i mean would ukraine have the
capability to actually physically attack
russian territory no i i mean not in any
significant degree there were reports of
what might have been a false flag attack
on oil storage just over the russian
border a few days ago and the ukrainians
said it wasn't them and maybe it was
maybe it wasn't but there's no there's
no real military logic because the
ukrainians would have to attack so deep
into russian territory to get the air
base to get the storage bases to
actually do any damage to the forward uh
positions that the you russians are
taking that they just can't do it and
and what they would do but by extending
the war that way they risk losing some
of the enormous support they've got in
the rest of the world they are fighting
a brilliant defensive war
and while they're clearly on the
defensive and doing so well
their best strategy is to kind of chew
up the russian forces as they come at
them rather than do what a what a more
modern military would do which is to get
at the rare areas and interrupt the flow
they can't do it and probably but in the
main it's the signaling isn't it saying
you invaded us and you must leave our
country we're no threat to you exactly
and that's a really important message
that zelensky has been putting you said
you know get your troops out of my
country and then we can talk about all
sorts of things but why would i talk
when you've invaded me and i've never
been a threat to you we have never been
a threat to you and we never would be
how could we be you know we're a small
country
we're a big country in europe but we are
a third of the size of you we are little
russia that's what you used to call us
there's no way we could ever attack you
is is the argument well here's another
question about uh russian forces and
we've been hearing for
some time about mercenaries haven't we
uh is there any evidence of mercenaries
fighting in ukraine mick asks that well
um on both sides well we've heard about
foreign legions joining the ukrainian
side but what about the russians we know
about this this
mysterious wagner group the wagner group
are there at least a thousand of them
have come back from africa and they are
you know they're a private security
company um they are
battle trained they're very hard people
um they've committed all sorts of acts
in africa and so there's about a
thousand of them believed to be there
the chechens are there as well and the
chechens are fighting um uh in um
mario paul uh and again reasonably
effectively there's no evidence yet that
some of these african groups have turned
up all the syrian groups there's even
rumors that the syrians have gone home
and um one of the things you have to
realize about some of these african
syrian groups some of them are not
fighters at all i mean the wagner group
are all professional hitmen really um
but some of these syrians are young lads
who sign up for the money you know
they're offered a lot of money to join a
unit to go to fight they don't care what
they're fighting for and they're sending
the money back home it's a classic case
um the thing about all of these groups
is that although some of them like the
chechens and the wagner group are
effective if they attack a village
because they're experienced fighters and
they're very well armed and so on but
they can't
fit in to a combined arms arrangement
they can't actually plug in to a
sophisticated military they can just act
as as a local militia and in many cases
thugs in one given area it's not that
they don't make a difference but they
don't ever really make a strategic
difference if you're talking about more
organized forces interesting you
mentioned strategic difference well
let's address an area that really is
making that um this from haida will nato
advisors be helping ukrainians plan
attacks against russians with
information from western intelligence
well
how much can you tell us oh well the
answer is for sure um
because western intelligence has been
helping the ukrainians as much as
possible
before the war broke out before the 24th
of february we had british river joint
aircraft i was called river joints that
kept at waddington and whether they were
flying from waddington or from
aquitarian cypress i'm not certain but
we had river joint aircraft and again
you could go onto public tracing apps
and see where these aircraft were going
and they were going up and down the the
border between ukraine and belarus and
with ukrainians full support of course
listening in their intelligence
gathering aircraft and they're listening
in to conversations listening can they
cover most of ukraine then
totally yeah and since the war started
not only river joint but all nato
aircraft and swedish aircraft who are
not members of nato been going up and
down the border listening to gather as
much intelligence and i can promise you
we are giving everything we can we think
is useful to you to the ukrainians i
want to imagine satellite imagery as
well everything everything i mean
without revealing sources i mean the
essence of intelligence is never ever
reveal your sources that's the the
fundamental principle you know you you
take a lot of hits before you reveal
your source so anything you give to an
ally never ever reveal your source so we
certainly won't be doing that but we'd
be giving them everything that can make
a difference to the battlefield that
they have to inhabit yeah short of
troops of course um yeah well uh here's
the question that's i can't it kind of
looms behind this entire conflict
doesn't it from johnny uh if putin
decides to use nuclear weapons how long
would it take for them to launch would
we have any indication
of the process what do you know about
the launch procedure yeah for the for
the russians it depends what sort of
nuclear weapons you're talking about if
we were talking as we i think we've
mentioned before that if we're talking
about tactical nuclear weapons the sort
that if you know if we got into this
issue and we're a long long way from
nuclear use at the moment but you know
we're in a war and things change quickly
or can
if we're talking about tactical nuclear
weapons that is one ones that the
russians would use on the battlefield in
relatively small explosions relatively
then yes there'd be quite a lot of
indications you could see them being
brought forward i mean nuclear arms are
not like any other ammunition you don't
just stick them on the back of a truck
so that you would we would see western
intelligence is looking very carefully
for any indications of this we would see
those munitions being brought forward
and we'd see the sort of of of dual use
um artillery that could fire them or
could aircraft that might deliver them
so yes there would be plenty of
indication of that if we were talking
about strategic nuclear weapons then mr
putin has
uh an ability to communicate directly
with his submarine commanders
and that would be a relatively quick
process that would give no warning um
unless it was politically warned unless
there was a series of political
statements so it would depend on which
nuclear weapon what about on our side
on our side it's um it's quite different
in that in the sense that um all nuclear
submarines british nuclear summaries
they carry a letter from the prime
minister the famous letter of last
resort so if all else fails you've got
no contact with the outside world and
you think a nuclear attack may have
taken place you open the letter which is
kept in a little cabinet in the
submarine in fact there's there's a
first sea laws letter in there as well
so what what the captain has to do is
open the first sea lord's letter which
tells him something and then open the
prime minister's letter which may say
the same or whatever so there's these
letters of last resort but that's in
this bizarre situation where a submarine
commander may think that that the rest
of the world has gone crazy and the the
commander's got to make his own
decisions in the more normal situation
prime minister is on a visit to
darlington and there's an issue and the
prime minister says right okay i have to
launch nuclear weapons
the prime minister's authorization
is at once i'm told and i don't know
what this is of course but the promises
authorization is unbreakable
but completely secure it's not it's not
a set of digits or a set of numbers it's
something that only that prime minister
can do or somebody who is standing in
for the prime minister because the prime
minister's having an operation on you
know on his heart or her heart or
whatever it is
and so the prime minister's
authorization goes to the ministry of
defense into the bunker underneath the
minister of defense
that then goes to fleet headquarters at
northwood
um and at northwood they contact the
submarine
in the submarine
the captain and the executive officer
open the uh the codes
they have to stand a long way apart and
they have to both turn a key and they
both have to turn this key within a
couple of seconds so not one person
can't do it both of them have to do it
long distance apart from each other and
that arms the weapon and it isn't a
button
it is a pistol grip
and so when the weapon is armed the
captain name picks up the pistol grip do
the countdown pressure the pistol grip
and the weapons launch how long does it
take
55 minutes
not really an incident everything i've
said is in the public domain i hasten it
indeed it's in the public domain i mean
fascinating michael but of course
entirely chilling we're going to take
another break i think we need one after
that you're watching a special question
and answer program on the war in ukraine
next we are asking
could ukraine sue for peace and on what
terms and also can putin hold on to
power we'll be addressing those issues
next
[Music]
i'm inzamam rasheed and i'm sky's north
of england correspondent telling stories
from this culturally rich region i call
home
it's going to become
very similar to other places and lose
its unique qualities it's steeped in
history
the taliban found your family what would
happen i think they're just going to
straight away execute them
there are issues of racism in all levels
of cricket i was in the balcony a couple
of times i was nearly gone
football is a joy to watch and when
people are disappointed you can feel the
hate
[Music]
i just felt physically sick so i was
like that that's really in my system
we take you to the heart of the stories
that shape our world
even before the pandemic gps were
pleading for help government expects
more face-to-face contact with patients
in return
men they want to foster doing something
which you don't want to do just because
you're homeless and you're looking for a
warm place to sleep
we give a voice to communities often
unheard and unserved from a region with
a distinct history and global impact
[Music]
[Music]
well welcome back i'm with professor
michael clark and your questions on the
war in ukraine uh let's put jeremy's
question to michael here he says russia
celebrates
uh russia says it is denatifying russia
could a major assault be ahead to
celebrate the defeat of nazi germany on
the 9th of may this has been much
speculated about michael isn't it that
somehow president putin wants some kind
of victory to to parade in red square on
may the 9th yes may the 9th is victory
day always has been i mean the second
world war ended on may the 8th 1945 and
so may the 9th is a very important
celebration in russia it always has been
and british and american intelligence
are saying they are convinced again this
is intelligence people speaking that
putin is now taking this very seriously
and so that kind of gives us a sense
that this offensive in the donbass which
is developing quite quickly is probably
designed to try to produce something in
the week before the 9th of may but here
we are on the 4th 5th of april there's
about three weeks so we might be facing
a rather intensive battle over three
weeks so that mr putin can say i've got
the whole of the donbass back i
personally think he'd be lucky to do it
but i think that's what he may want to
say but the interesting thing is this
this de-nazification thing it's gone
to ridiculous lengths now because his
argument is not just that the government
of ukraine our nazis the whole society
are nazis there was an article appeared
in the novosti the ria ria novosti um
news agency yesterday which is the state
news agency and it was an op-ed piece
and it said that ukrainians again don't
exist they just created themselves out
of uh the the little russia that used to
exist and the nouveau russia of um of
captain the great
and it said that the process of
denaturation will have to coincide with
the process of de-ukrainianization
and this article was the closest i have
ever seen in a newspaper that justified
genocide absolutely astonishing and that
doesn't appear although it appeared
under under a different name it doesn't
appear unless the kremlin approves it
and so the russians are clearly flying a
kite for a maximalist position which is
to say
that the whole of you ukraine has to be
de-nazified and tying it in with that
made trying to get in with the defeat of
it exactly
it's it's bizarre in the sense that the
war from putin's point of view
the the reality of the war is getting
smaller and smaller his aims are
becoming smaller but his his political
aims are bigger and bigger all the time
which is why i worry i'm haunted by the
fact or the idea that this may become a
more general european war before it's
all over okay well let's uh talk about
peace instead of expansion of the war
nick asks this uh what terms can ukraine
realistically agree to that would be
sufficient to stop the fighting well
it's the eternal question and of course
it's up to the ukrainians of course yeah
we have to we have to back whatever
their judgment is and my guess is again
zelinski has been very clever he said
look we can talk about neutrality we can
talk about nato we can talk about the eu
we can talk about um the status of
ukraine afterwards of course but you've
got to get out of my country first i'm
not going to talk when you're occupying
territory of mine or of our country now
i think that zolensky
understands that he's probably lost
crimea forever because they lost crimea
in 2014 very important part of ukraine
but it is 90 russian it is it is russian
it is thoroughly russian in culture and
outlook and i don't think ukraine in a
way would want crimea back because it
would have to struggle to maintain
control if it ever did so i my own view
is that you is valencia could say look
i'm making a huge concession here
ukraine's a very important piece of
territory very important place
historically culturally yeah if i agree
that you keep ukraine then you've got to
get out of the rest and that might be a
feasible negotiating position if the
russians continue to do badly but for
putin that would represent real failure
because it would meant that he he ended
the war with less than he started with
in territorial terms and remember putin
only seems to think about power in
territorial terms so in his
one-dimensional world that would be real
failure and he'd have to live with that
okay well let's stay with some kind of
end game to this war and uh martin asks
this given the destruction i mean
billions upon billions hundreds of
billions of dollars we've witnessed even
so far
can the russian financial assets held by
the west be seized and used to repair
the damage and rebuild ukraine some kind
of reparations for sure i mean in theory
yes i mean the russians began this war
with a kind of war chest so they had
foreign reserves of 630 billion dollars
which is a pretty big war chest they
found within the first week of the war
that half of them 310 315 i think it was
billion dollars worth had been impounded
uh had been frozen in the west so
they've lost half of their war reserve
at the stroke of a pen because they
didn't believe that the west would react
as strongly as the west did they've that
300 odd that they've still got is enough
to keep going and you know they're still
getting the money in for their energy
exports their gas and their oil less for
their coal these days and they won't get
much for their coal at all soon um so
they can keep financing the wall but yes
the west holds at least 300 billions
worth of dollars of russian money that
could well become reparations if there
were some sort of settlement in which
the russians admitted that they were
wrong they admitted that yeah we'd have
to be post putin
we'd have to be talking about a russia
after putin for that to happen that's
the question we want to put lastly uh
michael thank you for anticipating that
this from might come do you think that
vladimir putin could hold on to power
directly or indirectly what are the
chances of him being ousted hold on to
power directly or indirectly i mean he's
certainly not going to go voluntarily no
and he never was i mean we were saying
five years ago we said look there's no
peaceful transfer of power that we can
imagine in russia you know once he gave
himself power to stay in office until
2036 we began to call him vladimir the
indefinite you know we just didn't know
where
how this could how this could end well
i am on record of saying i think he will
go i think he will go maybe quite
quickly or maybe in two or three years
because he's leading russia into
a complete wilderness internationally
and i think the longer he stays the more
russia will be on its knees economically
by the time he does go but
uh what happens then let's follow that
scenario okay
do you get more putin do you get a
proper democrat or do you get civil war
do you get russia breaking up yeah all
those things are plausible my get my
guess is you won't get a nice person
after putin you might get a a putin ii
who then sees the reality of having to
rehabilitate russia within the
international community and then putin
three or the the next generation of
leader might then be someone that you
could deal with more reasonably but it
will be a difficult transition process
but i do think that's what we will come
to i do think that's where we will end
up
putin i'm i'm i'm happy to say live on
tv i do not believe he will last into
the 2030s i'm sure he won't
i know to end it on thank you very much
indeed michael uh professor michael
clark answering your questions
brilliantly on the war in ukraine and
you're watching sky news tonight coming
up
in the next hour well where can have the
latest on those alleged war crimes being
committed by russia in ukraine president
zielenski directly addressed the united
nations today about that and we'll have
full analysis
[Music]
they're images that have shocked the
world the ukrainian government says they
show evidence of war crimes by russian
forces and vladimir putin must be held
accountable russia claims the pictures
and video are fake what happens now well
on thursday i'll be speaking to one of
putin's closest advisers his press
secretary dmitry peskov watch the view
from the kremlin putin spokesman live at
5 pm on thursday